hey guys Pete here got some new Game of
Thrones Season 7 news yesterday which
will be a big spoiler if you don't want
to know possible speculation on how
season 7 will play out then you won't
want to watch this video yesterday
Watchers on the wall reported that they
have it from sources that the nearest
will be visiting the dragon pit in
season 7 this is pretty big news since
the ruins of the dragon pit are located
smack dab in the heart of King's Landing
so in this video I'm going to talk about
the trip what the dragon pit is and
later I'm gonna speculate on what might
happen there also I have a giveaway
going on for subscribers so make sure
you check out the details on that at the
end of the video the dragon pit is a
massive dome building that the Targaryen
is used to keep their dragons inside the
city walls
it's said that 30 Knights could ride a
breast into its entrance so it's pretty
massive it's basically a ruin now
blackened by fire since there haven't
been dragons in the city for over a
hundred years the dragon pits huge dome
is collapsed and its doors have been
sealed there are three big hills in
King's Landing that are named for the
original Targaryen conquerors egg on the
first made King's Landing as a seat for
his power the city of King's Landing and
the hill with the red keep has his name
the other 2,000 aim Rhaenys hill and
Visenya hill after his two sister wife
code conquers before there was a dragon
pit a great Sept was built on Rainey's
Hill which was called the Sept of
remembrance and it used to be the main
cept in King's Landing
during the faith militant uprising not
what we just saw but the you know way
back in the day the faith militant went
before they got wiped out completely
Targaryen king magar the cruel
incinerated the great Sept with Dragon
Fire and later decreed that a large
stone structure would be built on the
hill the plan was for Targaryen to house
their royal dragons there because maegor
had killed all of the people that he
used to build his red keep because he
wanted to keep them from giving up all
the secrets of the underground tunnels
and whatnot many of the remaining
builders in town fled rather than work
on the dragon pit so maker had to use
City prisoners with supervisors from the
Free Cities I mentioned that there
haven't been dragons in King's Landing
for a long time and this is primarily
because of the Targaryen Civil War known
as the dance of the Dragons we actually
know a lot about that conflict thanks to
George RR Martin's story the princess
and the Queen from that story we know
after King's Landing was captured by
queen rhaenyra
the dragon pit was
droid during an event that's called the
storming of the dragon pit during the
storming tens of thousands of crazed and
starving small folk led by an odd
character who they called the Shepherd
stormed the dragon pit to kill the
Dragons within 5 Targaryen dragons and
thousands of small folks were killed in
the storming of the dragon pit the
dragon pit was reduced to flaming runes
and during that time after that we don't
really have that much or haven't really
even heard that much that's happened
there except that we got a mention from
the Duncan egg story the Soren swore
during the great spring sickness so many
people died so fast that they there was
no time to bury all the bodies instead
they were piled up in the dragon pit and
when the corpses were about ten feet
deep Brendan Rivers who was the hint of
the king also known as blood raven or
three-eyed crow a three-eyed raven
ordered the pyromancers to burn them the
light of the fire shone through the
windows and by night citizens could see
the dark green glow of wildfire all
through King's Landing one side note is
that the Royal Dragons that the
Targaryen sceptic side the dragon pit
didn't grow as large as their ancestors
Tyrion actually references this in the
show when he says dragons don't do well
in captivity the maesters attribute this
to the Dragons being confined but if you
believe the masers have an agenda when
it comes to dragons like I do then it's
possible there were other things going
on as well so at this point you might be
thinking that we've seen we've spent a
lot of time in King's Landing over the
past six seasons how can I have totally
messed this giant structure well there's
no need to go back and re-watch anything
because the dragon pit so far has been
completely left out of the show this
isn't altogether surprising based on how
big it is and the fact that no story
lines or scenes have really required it
this map of King's Landing gives you an
idea where it would be though on the
right you see the red keep or Cersei
lives on the left the great Sept of
Baelor or that Cersei recently blew up
and then the dragon pit that would be
right over here
dragon pits showing up will be great
just like seeing the high tower last
season at Old Town was but that's not
really the most exciting part of this
revelation the most exciting part is
that this means Daenerys will definitely
be inside the walls of King's Landing
before Sivan Season seven comes to an
end well this has been heavily
speculated already this pretty much
confirms it the speculation now isn't
whether a Dany will advance on the city
but instead how it all goes down there
are a couple obvious ways this could
could happen but I think that we have to
entertain the idea of misdirection it's
possible that Danny could see the dragon
pit in a vision or dream so this whole
idea of leaking the location could just
be to fool us at the same time with only
13 episodes to go if she's gonna go to
King's Landing she's pretty much gotta
stop messing around and get there these
are the possible scenarios on how she
ends up there that I could think of she
could fly into the city while it was
still held by Cersei and choose the
dragon pit as a place to land or if she
could go there after defeating Cersei to
check out this part of her family's
history or Cersei could destroy the Red
Keep and flee to Casterly Rock and Danny
could come across the dragon pit as
she's checking out the other ruins or
the one that seems least likely Cersei
could welcome Daenerys into the city to
treat or in an effort to trap and
destroy her let me know what you guys
think in the comments is this
confirmation that Dany will be setting
up shop in King's Landing before the end
of season 7 is the cuz this confirmation
that Cersei is done for where are the
showrunners just having you know a bit
of fun with us with a pretty clever bit
of misdirection please like the video if
you found it interesting and please
subscribe to my channel to keep up with
all my latest game of Thrones related
videos I have a giveaway going on for
when I hit 18,000 subscribers where I'm
gonna give away a copy of a knight of
the Seven Kingdoms and all you have to
do is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video so subscribe now
and comment and thanks for watching
I'll talk to you soon